well I am an elitist proudly an elitist
I think it's really interesting in the
presidential campaigns that it was not
possible to suggest that even though all
the candidates were Harvard educated and
and and had gone through the most
prestigious private schools and whatever
that they had to identify themselves as
you know strictly populists and and so
I'd like to know why how America get to
be a real American you have to be a
bible-thumping rifle rifle toting shot
in a beer American to really be
considered American the thing I love
about our country is that you have the
opportunity to be an equal opportunity
elitist we are we don't have a class
system or something that doesn't allow
someone to move from one a set of issues
to another freely I mean anybody who
wants to become part of the elite that
is the Intelligencia the the people who
are concerned with the most rarified
kinds of issues has an opportunity to do
it we're not stuck in a caste system so
for me a you know kind of kid from a4ai
trash Milton I had opportunity to better
myself and not there were no no barriers
or restrictions in my way other than my
ability and my ability to my my my
abilities and my ability to navigate the
system so if you get scholarships and if
you get me do well and you proved
yourself you can move from here to there
and and end up and
the most elite circles and go through
the best institutions so it's that it's
the opportunity that's important because
I do think that there are things which
are more noble activities or things that
are more important to society than some
other things I'm not saying that people
who don't do these things there's
something wrong with them or their
deficient or they're not and I'm
valuable to our society I identify with
the worker and I am a worker i get up
every morning and I and I go in the
studio I worked 365 days of the year and
I i consider myself you know i love the
energy level of people walking in the
streets people are slipping stuff and
tearing things down and building it back
up I'm very much part of that of that
world in that mentality but I'm also
interested in trying to transcend my
entrance into the society and have
experiences that put me someplace else I
didn't want to say that it elevated me
because there's a there's a presumption
than that that you are better than the
people you were elevated above I don't
think that I just think movement he
moved from where you are to someplace
else and you have other experiences and
you can change the kinds of experiences
you have and and and lead a different
kind of life but it's it's not a a big e
elitism I'm better than you it's a it's
opportunity to do more than you were
originally exposed
you